[Música]
en Estados Unidos los organismos de
socorro busca en las tres Personas
Desaparecidas de quiénes se teme su
muerte tras los incendios devastadores
de Colorado que destruyeron cerca de
1000 hogares y obligaron a evacuar a
decenas de miles de personas
un efecto secundario de la pandemia de
covid-19 en el continente americano la
inflación en el 2021 las dificultades en
las cadenas de suministros generaron un
incremento de precios de bienes y
servicios y para el año que empieza los
expertos comentan sobre las proyecciones
Israel ataco objetivos de Hamas en la
Franja de Gaza el ejército dijo que así
respondió al previo lanzamiento de dos
cohetes de Palestina que causaron una
explosión en la costa de Tel Aviv no hay
reportes de heridos
regresamos con ustedes y tenemos más
noticias aquí en francés 24 el estado de
Colorado en Estados Unidos sigue
conmocionada por el devastador incendio
que durante días afecto varias ciudades
y arrasó casi me casas el sheriff del
condado de Boulder aseguró que al menos
3 personas están desaparecidas y se teme
su fallecimiento mientras tanto las
tareas de rescate continúan veamos el
informe
partido en dos por el dolor y la
conmoción William Klein regreso a su
hogar para inspeccionar los daños su
casa como casi otras mil fue destruida
por los rápidos incendios forestales que
arrasaron varias ciudades de Colorado
se encuentra en una sequía severa o
extrema y esas condiciones ayudaron a
que el incendio forestal se propaga a lo
largo de unos 24 kilómetros cuadrados
las familias de todo el condado
enfrentan la pérdida más de 30.000
tuvieron que huir muchos solamente con
la ropa que llevaban puesta lo que nos
duele
todos nuestros recuerdos fotografías
reliquias cosas que fueron ya sabes
el Departamento del Sheriff aseguro que
las misiones de recuperación de 3
desaparecidos que se cree que murieron
en el incendio continúan
a diferencia del primer año de la
pandemia en 2021 se terminó con una
tendencia al alza en los precios de
bienes y servicios de varios países del
mundo eso tiene una especial repercusión
en el continente americano con
incrementos y que no se veían desde hace
años en naciones como Estados Unidos o
Perú de las causas de este fenómeno y
sus perspectivas para el 2022 o nos
habla Juan Pupiales
una espiral inflacionaria por culpa de
la pandemia el impacto del covid-19 en
la economía del 2021 afecto sobre todo
la cadena de suministros globales esto
se tradujo en una dificultad para
satisfacer la demanda internacional es
un escenario que generado un alza de la
inflación de varios países por ejemplo
en Perú la tasa anual de 2021 fue del
6,43% una cifra impulsada sobre todo por
un repunte de más del 13% en vivienda
combustibles y electricidad y de cerca
del 8% en alimentos y bebidas para
Colombia las autoridades monetarias
auguran una inflación superior al 5% en
el año que termino muy por encima de la
meta en Brasil preocupa un índice de
precios que ya es de 2 dígitos a qué se
debe este fenómeno
política Estados Unidos no está al
margen el jueves no reporto que los
precios en noviembre subieron un 6,8% en
un año la inflación más alta en 39 años
lo que eleva la presión sobre las tasas
de interés de la Reserva Federal
de los bienes esenciales para el 2020
Estados Unidos anunció la exclusión de
Etiopía Mali Guinea del acuerdo
comercial que mantiene con los países
africanos para la administración de
yubay de los países han tomado
decisiones que violen los principios de
un buen gobierno y los derechos humanos
lo que va en contra de la hago a Leire
para el crecimiento y oportunidades de
desarrollo de África el acuerdo
comercial que permite el intercambio de
productos con bajos impuestos
funcionarios del gobierno Clinton
se produjo un incendio en el edificio
del parlamento de Sudáfrica en la Ciudad
del Cabo el gobierno dijo que la
emergencia trajo un día triste para la
democracia la ministra de Obras Públicas
e infraestructura Patricia del y le dijo
a los medios de comunicación el que el
fuego estaba ardiendo en la cámara de la
Asamblea Nacional pero que había sido
contenido en otras partes por el momento
no hay informes de personas heridas
tampoco se conocen las causas de la
conflagración el presidente Cyril
Ramaphosa felicito al servi bomberos o
por su rápida respuesta que salvo el
complejo
por supuesto que todavía vamos a
profundizar en las causas del incendio y
cómo se propagó desde la Asamblea
antigua a la Asamblea Nacional es algo
que todavía se investigara creo que
alguien está detenido en ese momento y
está siendo interrogado pero tenemos que
profundizar mucho más en cómo se pueden
llevar a cabo este tipo de eventos y qué
medidas tenemos que tomar en el futuro
gaviota café Layla las fuerzas aéreas
israelíes atacaron esta noche una serie
de objetivos una instalación de
producción de cohetes en camiones y
además varios juntos y avanzada en la
frontera de la Franja de Gaza esos
ataques son una respuesta en lanzamiento
de cohetes ayer desde la Franja hacia el
mar Mediterráneo
para el presidente de Emmanuel Macron a
tan solo en el primer semestre del año
el mandatario deberá liderar la
presidencia rotativa de la Unión Europea
y al mismo tiempo tendrá que afianzarse
en el electorado si espera lanzarse a la
religión una candidatura que aunque el
mismo no ha confirmado se da por hecho
informe de Manuela Cano
un año crucial y desafiante así se
perfila el 2022 para Emmanuel Macron con
el primer día del año ya llegó un gran
reto su presidencia rotativa de la Unión
Europea que catálogo como un punto de
inflexión
a partir de la medianoche Francia
asumirá la presidencia rotativa de la
Unión Europea y pueden contar con mi
compromiso total
deberá liderar al bloque europeo inverso
de un complejo panorama con la crisis
sanitaria que sigue asustando a Europa y
la reciente escalada de la tensión entre
Ucrania y Rusia aún así parece que el
presidente tiene sus principales
objetivos claros buscar a Elisa miento
de salarios mínimos en toda Europa la
regulación de los Gigantes digitales y
la creación de un impuesto al carbono
además de la protección de las fronteras
europeas frente a las crisis migratorias
un liderazgo que podría verse afectado
por su propia pugna presidencial el
mandatario no anunciado aún su
candidatura que muchos ven como
ineludible un gesto que podría deberse a
su deseo de no mezclar sus decisiones
políticas con su campaña presidencial su
carrera por hacerse de nuevo con el
Eliseo ya tiene un importante obstáculo
la candidatura de la conservadora vale
rey pesca es su principal rival que se
ha afianzado en una parte del electorado
en la próxima primavera las elecciones
presidenciales sean de condiciones y
verdaderas soluciones para Francia cerca
de 2 años de pandemia han golpeado
duramente al mandatario que además de
seguir lidiando con el aumento de los
casos deberá luchar contra la caída de
su popularidad
un positivo a su regreso de vacaciones
también están contagiados Juan Bernat de
Sergio rico y Natan between masala los
cuatro están aislados el París
Saint-Germain volvió este fin de semana
los entrenamientos y este lunes empiezan
los dieciseisavos de final de la Copa de
Francia contra elefantes de Cuarta
División
si en France 24 y en France 24.com
[Música]